las barreras de flexibles separaron a
los candidatos a la vicepresidencia de
eeuu pero no frenaron los evidentes
choques ideológicos de cada campaña de
américa
el pueblo estadounidense ha sido testigo
del que ha sido el mayor fracaso de
cualquier administración presidencial en
la historia de nuestro país
el presidente trombo hizo lo que ningún
otro mandatario había hecho nunca
suspendió todos los vuelos con china
esta decisión del presidente trump nos
dio tiempo invaluable para enfrentar a
la amenaza nacional más grande desde la
segunda guerra mundial sobre la economía
el candidato republicano aseguró que el
gobierno trump redujo impuestos y creó
empleos en la industria de combustibles
fósiles lo que hizo que el país se
recuperara su contrincante demócrata
respondió que el mandatario se dedicó a
reducir contribuciones de las grandes
corporaciones y ahora eeuu tiene un
déficit de 2 millones de dólares no
verás la guerra comercial con china fue
otro punto de discordia
afortunadamente desde el principio de su
administración el presidente trump le
hizo frente a china un país que ha
tomado ventaja de eeuu por décadas
contrario a joe biden que ha sido una
porrista de china
- trace la perspectiva y el acercamiento
de la administración de trompa china ha
derivado en la pérdida de vidas
estadounidenses de puestos de trabajo
estadounidenses y de liderazgo
estadounidense
los aspirantes también se enfrentaron
por sus posiciones sobre política
exterior que unirán medioambiente
derecho al aborto y el pago de impuestos
del presidente de donald trump entre
otros